amener chez vidéo
nous sommes dans vannes woodbridge la
candidate du parti conservateur en est à
sa première expérience en politique
teresa cruz est une ancienne journaliste
vedette de sport
cette circonscription est prête à se
débarrasser des libéraux auditeurs à
cruz elle sera bleu le 21 octobre
et elle sait bien que cette
circonscription et toutes celles de ce
qu'on appelle le 905 sont cruciales pour
former le prochain gouvernement
ce n'est pas un hasard d'ailleurs si
c'est là que son chef douch irs a lancé
sa campagne en ontario en quatre matches
a envoyé un message à nos électeurs
qu'il compte et kindu chine se préoccupe
d'eux
woodbridge non loin de toronto est une
circonscription assez cossu où vivent de
nombreux canadiens d'origine italienne
elle a basculé du bleu au rouge
il y a quatre ans mais a aussi voté
massivement en faveur de d'oxford au
provincial en 2018
cet agent immobilier à voter pour lui
mais laurent félix hésitent encore au
fédéral mais surtout pas que je voulais
avoir un devoir d'y siens en ontario et
en indochine au canada je veux une balle
ensemble ce qui est là dans la politique
provinciale ici parce que là vraiment
c'est trop conservateur si les deux sont
au pouvoir
alors en plus d'affronter les libéraux
teresa cruz doit composer avec cet autre
élément les faits fold car les
compressions du premier ministre
ontarien en santé en éducation en
culture ont causé un tel mécontentement
que bien des électeurs désenchantés
pourrait ne pas vouloir voter pour les
conservateurs à cause de lui comme fort
jayson canet en roussillon appartiennent
tous à une génération de politiciens
conservateurs pour qui le chef libéral
l'a bien compris jour après jour il
martèle le même message
votez pour un joshi c'est voter pour les
politiques de dr
le premier ministre ontarien s'est
d'ailleurs complètement éclipsé de la
campagne allait pas fait avec mais
teresa cruise se défend ce n'est pas un
facteur dogues fall dit elle c'est un
facteur justin trudeau twitter à nadal
combien de fois je frappe à une porte et
il soupire
quand je demande ce qu'il pense de
justin trudeau je ne vois pas pourquoi
on les compare 17 conservatrice de
toujours d'oxford s'est fait discret
pour aider indochine mais ils ont des
parcours et des objectifs différents
c'est vrai qu'ils appartiennent au même
parti messenger fait ce que dog a fait
s'il fait ce qu'il a promis on sera
content pour nos seniors mais rien est
encore joué dans ce marché public le
candidat libéral sortant serre des mains
consolide ses appuis
francesco sorbara est au coude à coude
avec son adversaire conservateur il y a
quatre ans il a été porté par un vent de
changement
même s'il affirme qu'on lui en parle pas
beaucoup aujourd'hui c'est peut-être
l'effet ford qui va faire la différence
ça donne une comparaison ou un choix
très clair dit-il sur ce qu'un
gouvernement libéral ou conservateur
fait nos personnes dans mon comté ne
veut d'un gouvernement qui coupent nous
on offre des services c'est la politique
mais les libéraux font aussi face à un
désenchantement laurent felix avait mis
beaucoup d'espoir en justin trudeau il y
a quatre ans
l'épisode du blackface entre autres
choses à ébranler sa confiance de ma
part j'étais déçu pas choquer un stage
lot de respecter le canada que ton père
tommy c'est un sujet délicat dans la
famille est ici là ça me fait mal qu'il
ait pu nous faire ça dit sa fille de 16
ans même si elle ne crois pas qu'il soit
raciste
j'ai été choqué honnêtement dit grèce on
ne s'attend pas quelque chose comme ça
du fils de pierre trudeau
même si c'était une blague je vais pas
dire aussi que je vais critiquer justin
trudeau sans voir c'est quoi les autres
options
peut-être c'est une question de choisir
celui qui est moins
- difficile à accepter il reste trois
semaines de campagne des débats et bien
du travail à faire sur le terrain à
vannes woodbridge la course est encore
extrêmement serré ce soir et dans cette
grande région de toronto
c'est là que l'élection pourrait bien se
jouer
[Musique]